bonsoir à tous l'ancien premier ministre
et sénateur président de la commission
des affaires étrangères et de la défense
jean pierre raffarin est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
grossir et merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous pour évoquer bien sûr la situation
de la france notre pays en guerre contre
le djihadisme comme l'a dit manuel valls
dans un discours vibrant et puissant ce
mardi alors comment élever les discours
et les actes bien sûr à la hauteur de la
situation et de la mobilisation inouïe
de la tente des français autour des
valeurs de la république ces questions
nous les aborderons avec perrine
tarneaud et nadège poljak de l' agence
france presse ne te porte votre
partenaire comme chaque semaine avec
dailymotion pour ce rendez-vous de
preuves par 3 de symboles d'abord
monsieur raffarin la une de charlie
hebdo la une de charlie hebdo des
survivants cette semaine mahomet on le
voit ses larmes son slogan je suis
charlie et puis ce titre tout est
pardonné comment est-ce que vous recevez
ce dessin de luz le coup tout d'abord
comme un acte de courage je pense que
nous faire ce journal cette édition de
ce journal dans ces circonstances c'est
déjà en soi quelque chose de respectable
de vouloir rester debout après ces
assassinats multiples je pense que c'est
profondément respectable et puis je
trouve que c'est à la fois un message
qui permet à charlie hebdo de rester lui
même de ne pas baisser sa garde de
continuer sa ligne mais en même temps ce
mot pardon qui était
force incroyable qui force le respect
lui aussi donc n'est en rien une
provocation janquin génial ou la
trompette un peu toujours on peut
toujours chercher sur ce type de
communication des critiques et que
peuvent faire là tu réellement les
adversaires si on regarde l'histoire de
charlie hebdo les circonstances de ce
drame
cette une est plutôt un acte de courage
respectable qu'autre chose un acte de
courage tout est pardonné a écrit luz au
dessus du prophète
on ne peut pas pardonner sur les bons
c'est très compliqué pardonnez qui
pardonne et quoi il est clair que le
pardon est une valeur supérieure mais
décrire ce mot simplement de le nommer
c'est quelque chose de très très fort
quand on est sérieux quand on est
charlie hebdo combien de vivre ce que ce
qu'on a vécu donc charlie hebdo continue
à avoir cette dignité que s est vrai que
les uns et les autres ont eu depuis ces
événements
auparavant c'était dans un contexte
complètement différent on pouvait
discuter les positions politiques depuis
le drame on est dans un contexte nouveau
il y a là une circonstance tragique qui
fait qu' on a un autre regard et le
regard qu'on porte la cde comment cette
création at-elle pu venir dans des corps
ensanglantés
c'est respectable difficile entre
douleur et larmes on le sait un autre
symbole fort de ce mardi jean pierre
raffarin vient c'est la marseillaise qui
a été reprise par tous les sénateurs
masson
alors ça a été un moment de communion
inouïe un qui ne s'était pas produit
depuis l'armistice de 14-18 de 1918 au
sais pas comment est ce que vous l'avez
vécu vous comme une grande émotion on
est encore quasiment les larmes aux yeux
c'est mais depuis dimanche on vit des
émotions très fortes
on n'a jamais connu ça en moi dans ma
vie politique je n'ai jamais connu cette
volonté d'être ensemble avec ce
sentiment paradoxal d'une tristesse de
la stratégie us de snow adversaire
terroriste donc de dépenser autant de
stupidité autant de monstruosité donc
d'un seul coup il y a 7
cette tristesse qui envahit puis l'autre
côté une forme de fierté est presque un
bonheur d'être ensemble et il est clair
que les français sans doute aussi
exprimé ce ce besoin de d'exprimer leur
vivre ensemble de dire on a besoin de se
serrer les coudes et finalement sans
doute que à la fois notre société mais
aussi peut-être notre débat politique qu
azan trop haut postaux finalement et les
clivages c'est peut-être quelque chose
dont on a un peu la roja parlera
finalement est tous ensemble comme
cendre dans ce parlement
ici au sénat c'était presque un moment
de bonheur oui quelle image est ce que
vous avez gardé une image qu'on n'aurait
pas vu par exemple devant les écrans
télévision dimanche puisque vous étiez
au milieu des dirigeants de la planète
qui avaient été conviés à l'elysée vous
donc comme ancien premier ministre est
ce qu'il y avait une image je pense que
les gens applaudissent ans d'écart où il
ya des personnalités
c'est assez étonnant ce qu'en général
les personnalités les nao ont bloqué les
gens qui ne pouvaient pas passer et on
faisait passer les quarts en général
tous les genres et hurler y aurait une
agressivité c'est comme quand vous voyez
une voiture officielle qui passe à un
feu rouge est tout le monde qui
klaxonnent là vous avez entendu les
applaudissements les applaudissements
qui recolle à la fois le premier
ministre israélien
et
hélas les autres le palestinien est à
côté et tout le monde applaudit
jamais un mot agressive pas un slogan
politique le silence charlie où la
marseillaise et donc au fond une forme
de temps extraordinairement paisible on
est là rassemblés par quelque chose qui
est plus grand que nous alors vous
l'avez dit face à la succession de
drames il ya eu donc une succession
heureusement de d'événements
encourageants et quelques jours après la
marche république est que vous évoquez
par exemple on s'aperçoit que le traité
sur la tolérance de voltaire devient un
best-seller dans les librairies en
france mais il ya aussi des signes
inquiétants dans certains collèges et
lycées jean pierre raffarin ou des
élèves qui sont nés qui ont été élevés
en france ont manifesté par exemple
l'autre jour le refus du deuil national
est-ce que la république recule
aujourd'hui dans l'école de la
république je pense que dans l'école de
la république
il ya un certain nombre d' îlots
aujourd'hui de fortes résistances
je ne sais si c'est l'idée de république
ou seulement à l'idée de france
d'ailleurs on peut se poser la question
s'il n'ya pas localisé dans un certain
nombre de lieux de la société française
d'hier îlots de résistance de l ouïe pas
de sentiments anti france je crois qu'il
y a ça existe j'ai été assez surpris de
voir et d'entendre des enseignants même
dans des classes de 6e qui n'était
certaines attitudes pas forcément de
boycott mais certaine attitude
irrespectueuse vis-à-vis du drame
donc je pense que il est clair que
c'est utile dans la société finalement
que tous les français aient le sentiment
de crier leur horreur
parce que ça nous permet d'identifier
les silences de ce conte pas cris mais
alors il faut les avoir mais
d'identifier et ce qu'il faut par
exemple un suivi de certains élèves et
de leurs parents
je pense qu'il est clair qu'il faut pas
considérer ça comme des actes de
légèreté et je pense qu'il faut être
attentifs à des comportements
en dehors de ce qui peut apparaître
comme potash est hélas il faut faire
confiance au savoir faire et au
professionnalisme des enseignants pour
faire la différence parce qu'il peut y
avoir des attitudes potage qui ne sont
pas des attitudes
elle en parle de l'indifférence de mais
parfois de la guerre civile de
l'agressivité et de l'expression d'un
sentiment vraiment y font des gens qui
finissent par avoir une haine de la
france
et cette haine de la france on peut pas
la laisser se développer et on la
découvre pas aujourd'hui jean pierre
sparaco lorsque vous étiez premier
ministre il y avait déjà eu un rapport
sur l'enseignement dans notre pays avec
certaines résistances à l'enseignement
de certaines matières comme l'histoire
par exemple donc on a trop tardé à
réagir
je pense qu'on atteint aujourd'hui des
proportions de la société qui sont des
proportions menaçante
je pense qu auparavant on était dans une
situation où on pouvait parler de cas
marginaux aujourd'hui nous sommes là
dans une situation maintenant où le
nombre de cas signalés
les incidents dans le système éducatif
qui ont été signalés à l'occasion de la
minute de silence sont trop nombreux
pour qu'on considère ça comme de la
marginalité c'est un problème qu'il nous
faut maintenant traité peut-on parler de
l'échec donc de l'intégration est ce que
vous vous entraînez analyse nicolas
sarkozy pour qui l'immigration crée les
difficultés thème de l'intégration comme
le communautarisme c'est vrai qu'il ya
des difficultés de l'immigration mais
d'abord ne parlons pas d'échec de
l'intégration
il y à des échecs mais il ya aussi de
très très belles réussites
n'oublions pas tout ce qu'ils sont dans
le système éducatif réussi voyons les
étudiants aujourd'hui à l'uni
la cité dans les grandes écoles tous
ceux qui sont issus de l'immigration et
qui sont là il ya les très beaux succès
donc je pense que tout ce qui est ou
tout noir ou tout blanc est au fond une
mauvaise vision des choses il y a des
succès de l'intégration mais il ya aussi
de graves échecs et au fond ce qui est
assez grave c'est que on a peint de
filet de récupération de ceux qui ont
subi un échec il faut pas imaginer
je pense par exemple il ya certains de
vos amis par exemple françois baroin et
xavier bertrand qui disent il faut
rétablir un service national
si c'est un service militaire je pense
que nos armées n'en sont plus là
insolite et national voilà le service
national sis est l'organisation d'un
suivi d'animations de formation un peu
l'idée républicaine de ce qu était le
service militaire autrefois mais sans la
dimension militaire qui est aujourd'hui
une dimension technologique
professionnel et qui est tout à fait
autre chose et on ne peut plus mettre
des jeunes aujourd'hui dans des
situations comme il était il ya une
vingtaine d'années les armées ont fait
de tels progrès aujourd'hui que
technologiquement
il nous faut des gens de plus en plus
qualifiés de plus en plus professionnels
mais l'idée qu'on est un service civique
on est une organisation je crois est une
bonne idée de tout le problème lui coûte
il faut bien voir la situation
aujourd'hui financière de notre pays et
donc là je crois qu'il faudrait qu'il y
ait sans doute une sorte de commission
nationale des priorités que le président
de la république réunissent certain
nombre de personnalités pour qu'on
définisse nos priorités notamment
budgétaires parce qu'on peut permettre
que nos priorités je crois par exemple
est-ce qu'on laisse la sécurité dans le
champ des restrictions budgétaires
moi je ne le crois pas je crois qu' on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui dire qu'on va me
lis mille hommes de l'armée d'optionnel
territoire national pour la sécurité et
laisser les incertitudes que nous avons
sur le budget 2015 la défense nationale
on nous dit qu'on va avoir deux
milliards 200 millions de recettes
exceptionnelles
aujourd'hui nous sommes au début du mois
de janvier au début d'année 2015
nous ne voyons pas le début de séance
est ce qu'il sait mettre fin à la baisse
des effectifs dans l'armée française je
paie des programmes et dany année après
année
je pense que nous avons une loi de
programmation militaire c'est une loi
qui exige un budget annuel de l'ordre de
31 milliards chaque année il faut
assurer ce budget annuel
donc on a deux noms la loi de
programmation militaire programmation
militaire tenons notre ligne donc ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui et il manque
quelques milliards il faut vraiment les
sortira à bercy avec des initiatives
budgétaires fortes cela veut dire qu'il
nous faut faire un certain nombre de
choix
donc je pense que cette commission
nationale des priorités devraient
pouvoir dire que justement les choix
budgétaires pour ce qui est de la
sécurité et ce qui concerne les jeunes
en difficulté devrait être prioritaire
alors pour la politique d'apprentissage
la politique d'alternance par exemple
besoin d'une certaine manière aussi est
associé à cela ça veut dire qu'il faut
une enveloppe nationale qui soit une
enveloppe je dirais poste charlie mais
c'est à dire qui puisse nous permettre
d'intégrer les actions nécessaires pour
corriger les dysfonctionnements actuels
encore une petite question avant
d'évoquer avec perrine tarneaud le
renforcement de l'arsenal anti
terroriste un socialiste malek boutih
prône la mise sous tutelle de certains
quartiers de l'état il estime que les
maires par exemple n'arrive pas à faire
face aujourd'hui est donc mal et guti
voudrait établir un ordre social et
politique stricte face au
communautarisme et aux extrémismes
religieux ce que vous partagez cette
idée d'une mise sous tutelle de certains
quartiers
je ne vois pas vraiment ce que cela veut
dire parce qu'une mise sous tutelle ça
veut dire qu'on remplace les équipes
municipales par des fonctionnaires par
des policiers ça veut dire qu'on
augmente les budgets considérables donc
donc je pense que c'est il faut sans
doute aider les collectivités
territoriales mais sur quoi il faut se
mobiliser
c'est un la sécurité de l'éducation
c'est pas une question de mise sous
tutelle des élus donnez leur les moyens
d'une politique éducative et d'une
politique de sécurité elle pour ça il
faut une commission nationale des
priorités et que ce soit fait de manière
au delà des d'équipage partisans je me
souviens avec jacques chirac comme nous
avions fait la commission stasi pour
faire le texte à propos du voile à
l'école on avait engagé une démarche qui
était multipartisane qui était
pluraliste de manière à déboucher sur
des consensus on verra la suite donc de
votre proposition une commission
nationale des priorités avec et bien un
consensus autour des grandes villes un
roulage la recherche d'un consensus
absolument on a compris que c'était
votre disposition d'esprit depuis le
début de cette émission va parler
maintenant donc de la réponse
sécuritaire avec perrine tarneaud mais
d'abord donc avec jérôme rabier ce qu'a
annoncé manuel valls après l'émotion et
le rassemblement place à l'action
législative pour répondre au terrorisme
par la voix du premier ministre le
gouvernement annonce une mobilisation
générale à une situation exceptionnelle
doivent répondre des mesures
exceptionnelles
mais je le dis aussi avec la même force
jamais des mesures d'exception qui
dérogeraient aux principes du droit et
les valeurs un texte pour renforcer les
moyens des services de renseignement est
déjà en préparation
un fichier des déplacements aériens
européens doit être créé et un nouveaux
fichiers de délinquants doit aussi voir
le jour
il obligera les personnes condamnées à
des faits de terrorisme ou ayant intégré
des groupes de combat terroristes a
déclaré leur domicile et à se soumettre
à des obligations de contrôle des
mesures qui répondent en partie aux
demandes de l'ump même si certains
voudraient aller plus loin si nous
devions pour un moment restreindre les
libertés publiques et la liberté
individuelle de quelques-uns alors il
faudra le faire que faisons nous pour
neutraliser les milliers de français
partis faire le djihad
si par malheur ils reviennent la
solution la seule c'est le placement
centres spéciaux de détention
ou en prison en un mot l'enfermement des
fous dangereux pour garantir la sécurité
des français
des prémices d'un patriot act à la
française du nom des textes mis en place
aux états unis après le 11 septembre
2001 et qui permettent la surveillance
sans contrôle judiciaire
mais d'autres voix se font entendre
comme celle de robert badinter ou du
défenseur des droits chaque tout bon il
est clair que si on envisageait une
législation de ce type du type patriot
act
je serai amené en tant défaut serait
droit à dire très clairement que un
certain nombre de droits fondamentaux
sont touchés nous avons probablement
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de mesures
à prendre qui ne relève pas d'une
nouvelle loi
si les parlementaires sont pleinement
engagés dans l'après en janvier c'est
aussi ils l'ont tous rappelés par
l'éducation la transmission de valeurs
et de principes que le combat contre le
terrorisme pourra être gagnée sur ce
dossier crucial le renforcement des
mesures de sécurité nationale il veut
aller vite il veut frapper fort et la
raison bien sûr je pense que il est
important d'agir de pouvoir trop en quoi
notre système inconnu des failles
essayer des corrigés je pense que sur le
renseignement je pense que sur un
certain nombre de sujets sur la
situation pénitentiaire sur les sujets
qui ont été évoqués
il faut qu'il y ait des mesures qui sont
prises jusqu'à un patriot act à la
française
bon tout ça faut faire très attention
parce que ça c'est un peu les crimes des
choses valais les subtilités sémantiques
des mesures exceptionnelles mais pas
loin
donc faisons ce qu'il faut c'est que
on puisse vraiment se poser un certain
nombre de questions sur l' isolement en
prison des dangereux djihadistes donc qu
on est d atteindre l d'apparat bien sûr
que le fait qu'on puisse suivre ceux qui
reviennent de camp d'entraînement je
suivre simplement tout simplement si
vous voulez mettre en prison ça tout
tout dépend tout dépend là je peux je
pense qu'il faut des règles de droit
sont les règles de droit mais aller
jusqu'à la déchéance de nationalité
la déchéance de nationalité si les gens
sont dangereux s'ils ont commis des
actes
c'est en droit c'est le passage à l'acte
qui est donc on peut faire du préventif
mais il faut le faire selon un certain
nombre de respect de droits donc ce que
dit jacques toubon est très important le
pays des libertés pour citer un pays
d'état de droit donc on ne peut pas
toucher un droit individuel à olivet
s'il faut pas toucher un certain nombre
de droits mais tous les tribunaux
liberté est restreinte
je pense que sur internet sur un certain
nombre de sujets il faudra s'attendent
en effet à ce qu'il y ait un certain
nombre de contraintes je pense qu'il
nous faut et il faut accepter l'idée que
on pourra avoir des contraintes les uns
les autres
peut-être que vous journalistes vous
serez obligés aussi d'avoir des
contraintes pour ne pas forcément
dévoiler l'identité d'un fuyard
quand il est recherché par la police en
sélection je pense qu'il ya un certain
nombre de choses dont il faudra parler
moi je pense que ces sujets là ils
doivent être évoqués de manière
consensuelle dans le pays enfin il est
difficile de commencer sur ces sujets
mais aujourd'hui c'est que l'union
nationale c'est frais c'est repoussé des
jeunes moi je ne crois pas que non
l'union s'effrite c'est pas parce que
justement le débat en a on a des
questions qu'il faut ajuster mais nous
c'est à nous responsables de ne pas
faire de ces difficultés des polémiques
et au contraire d'essayer de voir
comment on peut agir de manière claire
et donc d'essayer de voix on a déjà jean
pierre afin que quand même le débat
reprend entre ceux qui prônent le tous
ces critères le tout carcéral et puis ce
qui donne la priorité à un discours plus
culturel non médication la prévert mais
moins la voyez vous êtes dans une
quiétude d'avant je pense que
maintenant une latitude post 11 janvier
ça va être quoi là je pense que il faut
regarder ce qui peut être acceptable
efforts pour le pays moi je ne veux pas
entrer dans une guerre droite gauche sur
les questions de sécurité
donc je veux qu'on discute moi j'ai mes
propres convictions je veux voir et
entendre les conditions d autres donc je
crois qu'il faut arrêter les postures
idéologiques
justement il s'agit pas de dire on va
être comme les américains on est
français il nous faut une attitude à la
française c'est à dire mettre le curseur
entre sécurité et liberté qui sont qui
soit compatible avec la tradition de la
france mais il est clair qu'il faut pas
être naïf et donc il ya des gens qui
sont dangereux ces gens là il faut les
mettre hors d'état de nuire
mais ce débat il vient déjà d'avoir lieu
au parlement puisque vous venez
d'adopter la loi 15 9 2 novembre 2014
elle est déjà caduque cette loi
cazeneuve
non les paquets duplain doit être
prolongé on a certains jeux ne sont pas
encore pu mais oui je vois que le
gouvernement accélère les décrets mais
par exemple que nous avons fait vous
savez qu'il existe une délégation
parlementaire du renseignement
monsieur revaas a fait un rapport c'est
dans ce cadre là où il ya beaucoup de
propositions pour réformer notre système
d'information je pense que il y à un
certain nombre de décisions
d'aujourd'hui doivent être prises sur
les fichiers
en ce qui concerne les transports
aériens et au niveau européen sur le
code de schengen
on a un certain nombre de choses qui
doivent être aujourd'hui engagés dans
des situations qui sont bloqués au
niveau européen notamment avec des pays
qui refusent d'échanger des informations
d'autres qui s'inquiète des atteintes à
la liberté de circulation
est-ce que vous pensez que les attentats
de la semaine dernière en france vont
faire bouger les lignes
je laisse au niveau européen je pense
qu'elle bouge en france quand vous voyez
les français ce que dans le buzz
dimanche il ya déjà eu des échanges
assez
hier on était très mêlée il y avait des
gens de tous les continents donc
l'expression européenne n'était pas
groupé mais on était c'était vraiment
une expression mondial dimanche
mais ni vos repères mais je pense que ça
fait bouger les choses
lorsque les français eux mêmes sont en
train de bouger je pense que les
allemands sont en train de bouger et on
voit bien qu'il faut trouver une ligne
qui sera en ligne une ligne de droit
mais qu'ils soient une ligne responsable
et pas naïfs alors que l'un des clivages
importants vous allez dire peut-être que
c'était avant le l'esprit du en janvier
signalant schengen vous l'avez évoqué un
et là il ya un clivage de saynètes entre
eux on va dire la droite et la gauche et
le comment faire évoluer selon vous
schengen nom est il une part de
responsabilité de schengen dans la
navigation est comme cela et djihadistes
entre les mains on peut pas dire que
schengen soit directement un sujet lié à
ce qui s'est passé
alors parlons chantier mais pour les
attentats parce que ce sont des français
qui ont agi et donc là nous sommes dans
une situation qui est différente mais
naturellement la question de
l'immigration
se pose également et qui mène le pose un
certain nombre de sujets voit bien par
exemple que c'est par un certain nombre
de flux migratoires que les gens du
djihad reviennent mêlé à un certain
nombre d'immigrés clandestins donc on
voit bien que là il ya des réseaux et
que l'immigration est concerné mais il
faut pas faire de l'immigration là la
sunna conditions où la source du
terrorisme l'immigration est un facteur
de complexité
un facteur qu'il nous faut mieux
maîtrisée et c'est clair qu'on voit bien
que les djihadistes qui rentrent en
france c'est pas ils rentrent par les
mêmes portes
on connaît les portes y sont les paris
kelly rendent ce sont les portes où il
ya des trous dans la raquette du temps
et donc c'est à dire là où schengen ne
fonctionne pas comme il devrait
fonctionner donc il est clair que
schengen doit être amélioré mais voyez
il faut être tout à fait prêt dans
tempéré parce que nous avons des menaces
avec des années
les ducs qui sont français voilà donc la
question là non pas une question
d'immigration mais ce sont des français
janice qu'il nous faut maîtriser alors
quelques questions maintenant sur les
opérations extérieures de la france
puisque vous êtes on rappelle présent la
commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat déjà sur l'irak l'intervention
militaire française a été reconduite ce
soir par le parlement français est ce
qu'on va est ce qu'on fera l'économie
d'une intervention au sol de nos troupes
je pense que la france doit faire
l'économie de cette intervention
j'étais le premier ministre de jacques
chirac qui avait souhaité la
non-intervention et je ne regrette pas
cette décision je pense qu' il faudra
une intervention un moment ou un autre
alors qu'il amènera ça c'est une
question aujourd'hui qui très difficile
il ya un certain nombre d'hypothèses
mais en tout cas ce n'est pas le rôle de
la france et je trouve que notamment
avec nos amis européens mais pas
seulement la france mais ça paraît plus
que sa part pour la défense des libertés
et la lutte contre le terrorisme dit sûr
de son fait trop et elle en fait trop si
loin de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui sur
le sol national je pense que nous sommes
directement concernés par ce qui se
passe et il faut aller attaquer nous
sommes en guerre
nous sommes en guerre contre le
terrorisme et il faut à la fois avoir
une action intérieure et l'action
extérieure et l'action extérieure il
faut aller là où l'ennemi est concentrée
l'ennemi console concentrés aujourd'hui
en irak dans la zone subsaharienne où
des quais qui est donc concernée par nos
opérations et donc là nous avons à
intervenir je pense qu'il faut à
l'iphone est la grande question de mon
point de vue sur cette intervention
c'est la durabilité
donc la question budgétaire du budget de
la défense vous savez que senna a refusé
le vote parce que on considère que
aujourd'hui le financement de la loi de
programmation militaire n'est pas
assurée n'est pas certain et donc là on
a une vraie question parce qu'on demande
de plus en plus d'interventions avec de
moins en vu venir les garanties rideau
vert je pense qu'il y a une idée qui est
très importante nicolas sarkozy l'a
développée dès dimanche soir où dès
lundi matin
je pense qu'elle est très importante
c'est l'idée que la sécurité soit hors
du périmètre
restrictions budgétaires ça vous
partagez cette solution je revendique ce
show là c'est un point très important
d'une manière générale d'ailleurs avec
un excellent il faudrait qu'on puisse un
jour discuter est ce que on ne peut pas
mettre une tare de nos crédits défense
qui sont des crédits en fait au service
de l'union européenne et de nos valeurs
le les met en dehors d'un certain nombre
de critères puisque là c'est un travail
que nous faisons de la france pour les
autres et donc là je pense qu'on devrait
admettre une situation spécifique pour
ces lignes budgétaires et est-ce qu'on
va pouvoir contourner une intervention
également en libye qui devient un
sanctuaire de djihadistes il ya
plusieurs pays du sahel qui appelle à
une intervention en libye
je pense que c'est très préoccupant et
je crois qu'on aura du mal pas
intervenir
ce sera quelque chose de très difficile
nous verrons mais les choses telles
qu'elles se présentent aujourd'hui font
que la france sera appelé à un moment ou
à noter la france encore alors toujours
dans le cadre d'une coalition je ne sais
pas comment les choses se présenteront
je pense que pour le moment la position
qui est prise par les autorités
françaises est sage c'est à dire qu'elle
est prudente mais je pense qu'il faut
hélas que qu'on prévoit un jour sans
doute d'être concerné par les airs quand
quelqu'un je ne peux pas vous le dire je
ne le souhaite pas donc je suis
naturellement là dessus comme bruce
était né viable non c'est pas inévitable
mais c'est qu'un probable c'est quand
même très probable
c'est quand même très bon l'homme à la
fois par notre presse à la fois par
notre histoire sur ce dossier à la donc
je pense que nous sommes très très
concerné par ce qui se passe
d'autres pays sont très concernés je
pensais à l'egypte et quelques autres
donc il y aura sans doute des
discussions mais je pense qu'il sera
difficile que la france ne soit pas
appelée comment la france répondra dont
le verront et nicolas sarkozy s'étaient
mués lundi matin lorsqu'il est intervenu
à la radio du fait que
la coopération entre les services de
renseignement français et marocains soit
coupée est-ce que vous aussi vous êtes
préoccupé par ces relations
diplomatiques difficile entre la france
et le maroc
oui je pense que c'est un sujet
important on interrogera d'ailleurs le
gouvernement sur ce sujet aux prochaines
questions d'actualité au sénat jeudi
c'est un sujet important on ne peut pas
être en lutte contre le terrorisme sans
avoir des discussions approfondies des
échanges et une coopération avec les
pays qui sont notamment pendant cette
rare qu'un diamant concerné dans cette
région donc c'est près de l'algérie
c'est près du maroc c'est le prêt de la
tunisie c'est vrai mais c'est vrai de
toute la zone méditerranéenne et d'autre
mais j'ai l'expérience peut notamment à
propos des otages pendant les
difficultés de la période irakienne vous
jacques chirac avait combattu les états
unis férocement pour ne pas intervenir
et convaincre un certain nombre de
bureaux y compris des voisins des états
unis comme le mexique ou le canada de ne
pas intervenir en irak ce que les
américains
vous savez beaucoup reproché malgré ces
reproches malgré ces désaccords
les services de renseignement américains
nous donner des informations et nous ont
permis quelques voix de sauver nos
propres otages
donc il est possible d'avoir des accords
politiques des désaccords politiques
mais en même temps d'avoir des sur les
questions de sécurité des opérations
je pense qu'il faut trouver les accords
nécessaires de coopération avec les pays
qui sont concernés vous dites que
l'europe qui juge le déficit budgétaire
devrait tenir compte de nos dépenses
militaires mais ce que l'europe devrait
être d la france financièrement non
voisins qui ne participent pas sur le
terrain qu'est-ce qu'on aille jusqu'à
mais manuel vals oui bon
moi je vous préférez qu'ils
interviennent je vis je suis très
attaché à notre indépendance nationale
et l'idée de recevoir des subventions
pour la défense c'est une idée dont il
faudrait discuter
moi je pense que l'indépendance
nationale partir du moment là là sur ce
sujet faut qu'on en discute
nous prenons l'état moi je d'esprit
c'est scène pas de combattre c'est
d'essayer d'échangé traduisent donc je
pense que l'indépendance nationale est
très important et donc ce que je
voudrais c'est quand on a une
intervention importante comme celle par
exemple que nous faisons en afrique que
les allemands qu'un certain nombre de
partenaires puissent s'engager librement
dans leur indépendance nationale
mais collectivement tous ensemble et
chacun respectant l'indépendance de
l'autre c'est clair merci beaucoup
perrine la dispute jacques dont deux de
l'agencé france-presse arrive maintenant
jean pierre raffarin on va pouvoir vous
allez pouvoir exprimer votre jugement
sur la façon avec laquelle l'exécutif un
gère cette crise est donc cette guerre
depuis la semaine dernière une
approbation il faut le dire tout de
suite surtout les rangs politiques marie
brémaud
c'est l'image du jour françois hollande
aux côtés des policiers pour rendre
hommage aux forces de l'ordre tombés
pour défendre le pays
ce sont les mots du jour c'est du père à
une nation meurtrie l'unité celle que
nous avons montré qui est notre arme la
plus solide qui est notre force ce
rassemblement ce que les français sont
capables de faire quand l'essentiel est
en cause
depuis une semaine chaque jour françois
hollande incarne tour à tour le chef de
guerre
le père réconfortant l'homme d'état le
président au dessus des partis
un sans-faute saluée par la classe
politique française y compris à droite
moment rare dans l'hémicycle un
centriste fait applaudir par l'ensemble
des députés le chef d'état et son
gouvernement
nous tenons à saluer l'attitude du
président de la république votre
attitude salimi de l'intérieur de
l'ensemble du gouvernement face à ces
attentats
moi je rends hommage à françois hollande
qui qui a pu mobiliser et tous les
français sont derrière lui comme chef
d'état et comme chef de la nation dans
cette tragédie que le monde entier
visant sa chair celui qu on raillait
hier encore affublés de surnoms tels que
flamby incarne désormais l'unité le
rassemblement du peuple
manifestement françois hollande fait
partie de ces gens qui se révèlent en
circonstances de crise extrême
c'était aussi le cas de jacques chirac
avant lui jacques chirac était quelqu'un
qui avait une communication assez
maladroite assez raide assez gauche sauf
dans les situations de crise extrême
comme la guerre en irak où là il se
révélait être à la hauteur de la
fonction présidentielle et c'est le cas
pour françois hollande c'est la première
fois depuis qu'il est président de la
république qui lie à unanimité sur le
fait qu'il ait été à la hauteur dans le
fait d'exercer d'habiter la fonction les
français le regard de différemment
désormais reste à savoir si c'est
passager ou si cela durera jusqu'à la
fin du quinquennat
80% des français salue l'action de
l'exécutif selon un sondage harris
interactive pour nos amis et confrères
de lcp-assemblée nationale bonsoir alors
est ce que le président françois
hollande et son premier ministre manuel
valls ont fait ce qu'ils devaient faire
bien sûr je pense que ils ont été dans
ces circonstances dans une posture qui
était celle que le pays attendait il
souhaite aussi à la hauteur de
l'événement est à la hauteur de
l'événement mais s'ils voulaient ils ont
enclenché ce phénomène d' d'unité
nationale politique par des signaux mais
aussi par l'expression d'une volonté
populaire parce que le la force elle
vient du peuple dans ce grand et on
lâche voilà c'était la tante quand
compte dimanche ont circulé mais y'a
sait pas y avait eu hollande et sarkozy
venu il y avait des gens balcons partout
il y en a pas un qui lisent et vive
sarkozy ou à bas sarkozy lui volant
doivent à olemps d'habitude on entend
toujours au moins un petit malin qui
dans la foule crie quelque chose avec
plus ou moins d'humour en faveur ou en
défaveur
l'un rien du tout le silence les uns et
les autres avancer sans qu'on en entende
quelques mots et quelques agressif dès
que vous donniez to marry you
consécutifs vous vous dites que nombre
de données non non non non je suis
naturel
je me dis oh non je dis qu'ils ont bien
géré la situation que ce qui est très
important aujourd'hui c'est quand même
la volonté populaire d'union nationale
qui l'ont bien compris que nous aussi
nous l'avons compris que nous aussi nous
avons écouté que nicolas sarkozy tu les
uns et les autres tout le monde a bien
compris l'exigence d'union nationale
exigence d'unité ce que je veux dire
c'est que maintenant tout va dépendre ce
que nous en faisons de ce patrimoine
on a créé un 13 heures ce trésor il est
partagé par tous qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
le président la république en premier
c'est à lui de gérer ce capital là d'une
certaine manière nous lui donnons notre
confiance dans cette situation qu'est ce
qu'il va en faire
quelles sont les initiatives à prendre
est-ce qu'il va changer les lignes
politiques tradition est-ce qu'il va
considérer qu'il y à un après en janvier
est-ce qu'il va inventer des formes
nouvelles d'action politique
est-ce qu'il va bouleverser un peu ses
habitudes et celle de ses amis y celle
de son parti c'est cela l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est où il a posé les mêmes
questions monsieur riverains pouvaient
aussi ça sauf que lui est au pouvoir
donc c'est lui qui doit prendre à sa
prison elle partie de l'initiative
non moi je pense que nous avons si le
travail j'espère que ceux qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui vois dans mon
attitude cette volonté sincère d'avoir
une attitude une nouvelle essayé de nous
mettre à la hauteur de la grandeur du
qu'est-ce que vous voulez à ne plus voir
le sectarisme politique c'est à dire les
attaques systématiques sur l'action du
gouvernement précédent
c'est à dire l'incapacité de passer du
temps encore une fois vous voulez pas
qu'on critique le gouvernement précédent
mais vous même vous critiquez ce
gouvernement alors est ce que ça veut
dire que vous allez mettre votre
différence en sourdine et pour combien
de temps alors je pense qu'il faut
essayer de dégager
des actions communes ça ne veut pas dire
que les différences n'existe pas selon
est toujours l'opposition
l'opposition est toujours l'opposition
mais ce qui nous est reproché souvent
par l'opinion publique
c'est la stérilité de nos débats c'est
la stérilité de nos différences c'est
notre impuissance à l'action c'est ça
qui nous est reproché
donc moi ce que je dis c'est qu'on peut
garder des différences mais qu'on a un
devoir d'action
aujourd'hui on a un devoir de trouver
les mesures qui vont protéger les
français et donc ce qui compte ce n'est
pas de dire regardez ce qu'ils font
c'est mal et quand nous on se rend
pouvoir ce sera mieux
c'est d'ensemble de travailler à ce
qu'il y ait des mesures qui protègent
les français les français ils ont
exprimé cette forme de deux messages un
peu sacré d'unité nationale maintenant
ce trésor là il est dans les mains du
président que va en faire le président
et s'il fait de ce capital là un
investissement dans l'action nous serons
à ses côtés
moi je militerai pour que nous soyons à
ses côtés si tout ça est fait pour qu'on
puisse agir dans ce que nous demandent
les français c'est à dire de la fermeté
pour la liberté d'autres sujets encore
l'économie pourquoi alors concrètement
ça mais l'allemand macron alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait
je pense que sur un certain nombre de
sujets il faut que le président trouve
les circonstances pour que notre débat
politique s'exprime d'une nouvelle
manière par exemple sur les territoires
la consultation a été la concertation a
été très superficiel il yal en
approvisionnant on va pas j'imagine que
non on va pas recommencer cela mais il y
a un certain nombre de sujets d'avenir
sur la loi macron il ya des discussions
qui peuvent être nous cela loin macron
la seule chose que nous disons c'est que
il faut aujourd'hui faire beaucoup plus
pour les pme
aujourd'hui l'emploi ces fonds dans
notre pays et donc il faut mener des
actions important on n'a pas touché aux
sujets qui fâchent par exemple le niveau
des seuils
aujourd'hui il faut doubler de mon point
de vue les seuils de salon c'est sociaux
et fiscaux les obligations
les seuils administratif il ya beaucoup
de seuil dans la ville d entre eux et il
ya beaucoup de paperasse ya beaucoup de
besoins de simplification nous avait
promis un choc de simplification de la
vente a donc ces sujets là je pense
qu'il faut les traiter tous sens en ce
qui me paraît être aujourd'hui la
responsabilité du président de la
république sait que sur ces débats là où
il continue en disant je travaille avec
le parti socialiste avec mes
parlementaire et mon gouvernement je
propose un texte et je fait voter mais
députés même s'ils sont frondeurs jeu
les oblige à voter et on fait un match
droit d'auge et comme j'ai la majorité à
l'assemblée
je fini par passer ou alors je cherche à
faire en sorte que le débat soit fertile
les français veulent de la fertilité
politique et non pas ils veulent de
l'action faire menu les autres activités
voient la ccc de la fermeté pour la
liberté de la fermeté pour l'action
c'est à dire ils veulent qu'on agit
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le sentiment
c'est un sentiment d'impuissance
pourquoi sur ces questions de terrorisme
et de situations de guerre nous avons
une relation avec l'opinion qui peut
paraître meilleur pour l'exécutif c'est
parce que nous sommes sur un terrain où
l'action politique a des moyens parce
que là vous êtes dans le régalien
là vous êtes en fonction de décisions
que vous pouvez prendre les gendarmes
les policiers les militaires
quand vous êtes dans l'économie il faut
travailler avec les entreprises
c'est plus compliqué d'une certaine
manière donc ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre aujourd'hui ce que demande le
pays c'est que le politique soit acteur
d'un certain nombre de changements
soient engagés dans l'action
plus que dans les débats semblent si on
comprend bien ce que vous nous dites à
partir de maintenant il va y avoir une
nouvelle donne dans le pays entre
majorité et opposition moi je pense que
c'est le défi qui est posé à françois
hollande
tout ça pour lui l'arrêté nouvelle oui
parce que vous vous n'êtes pas d'argent
non mais ça c'est très important parce
que quitte le conseil des ministres qui
décident d'un texte qu'ils adoptent
celle concédée nice qui l'adoptent nous
ne sommes pas en conseil des ministres
donc il ya vous êtes prêt à remplacer
une partie de sa majorité turbulente
parce que là ça dépend d'un certain
nombre de textes moi je pense
aujourd'hui qu'il ne faut pas hésiter à
voter des textes qui vont dans la bonne
direction
quand on estime qu'ils vont dans la
bonne direction c'est au président de la
république de faire en sorte que les
textes soient préparés soit plus ouvert
si nous revenons dans un débat droite
gauche traditionnelle ce sera un échec
de françois hollande c'est lui qui
aujourd'hui à la responsable lui qui
profite d'une certaine manière et je ne
lui reproche pas de ces deux têtes au
fond d'une posture régaliennes qui est
forte
il est en train de recevoir de la part
des autres formations politiques mais
aussi du pays une sorte de trésor de
consens juge national ou d'unité
nationale ce trésor est dans ses mains
chat se traduit à court terme par des
points dans les sondages mais à moyen
terme ça ne sera validée ce ne sera
exprimée que si ça débouche sur de
l'action et je peux vous dire que le
risque pour le président sexy à par
action qui lie à déception et qu'après
il verra que ce serait très difficile et
je pense que l'intérêt du pays l'intérêt
supérieur du pays
c'est que les français ne soient pas
déçus par le monde politique
après ce qu'il vient de se passer donc
ça c'est quelque chose de très important
et je pense que c'est pas à nous de
prendre le mistigri de la division et
donc en ce qui concerne l'opposition et
vous avez vu nicolas sarkozy
je pense que dans son intervention lundi
matin il n'y avait aucune faute sur ce
terrain là et est ce que c'est alors
c'est difficile dans un moment pareil
d'être dans l'opposition
non parce qu'enfin ce qui est difficile
c'est de faire face à des réalités
tragique dire que aujourd'hui moi je ne
suis pas dans la situation où je me dis
est ce que c'est bon pour nous pas bon
pour nous je me dit comment on peut
créer dans le pays
une forme d'état d'esprit qui fait que
le retour à des événements comme ceux
que nous avons connus la semaine
dernière soit impossible mais cela vous
nous avez quand même décrit un monde un
petit peu idéale où majorité et puis
opposition marchent main dans la main en
réalité ce n'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe et la preuve c'est que en 2010
elle vous voulez le pouvoir vous n'allez
pas le partager avec ces socialistes
vous voulez pour vous et pour l'avoir
pour vous faut bien vous placiez comme
opposition faut bien vous faciliter les
choses ici
réfléchissez bien cvo qu'il souffrirait
premier parce que si on supprime un peu
opposition majorité c'est les médias qui
sont bien embêtés parce que c'est les
médias ont besoin de l'un et de l'autre
qui si ce n'est pas que je peux vous
dire en relation en grande partie la
grande parce que je crois c'est qu'il ne
faut pas supprimer les différences mais
il faut pas faire des différences de la
stérilité
il faut pas faire des différences de
l'impuissance il faut pas que le jeu
politique consiste à empêcher l'autre
d'agir
les différents ça doit nourrir une
action c'est toute la difficulté de la
situation de monsieur hollande
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose de
difficile mais c'est à lui de faire en
sorte que les différences soient
positives et se transforme en narration
concrètement voulait pas qu'on retoque
tout aux amendements comme ça c'est
passé d'ailleurs pour la loi sur le
terrorisme oui mais je pense que ce que
j'aurais voudrait c'est la dernière loi
sur la sécurité dont les décrets
d'application n'ont toujours pas été
pris je pense que c'est un certain
nombre de choses comme ça c'est que ce
qu'il faut qu'on puisse tenir compte des
uns des autres que parce que vous pensez
par exemple que ségolène royal fait un
pas peut-être dans votre direction dans
le box france quand elle dit aujourd'hui
qu'il est nécessaire de construire de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires en france
alors qu'elle a fait voter un texte de
transition énergétique on le sait que va
d'ailleurs bientôt examiner le sénat qui
vise à réduire la part du nucléaire
eh bien ça surprend mais j'approuve
ségolène royal
vous appréciez donc nommer ce que c'est
clair qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'options comme ça je pense qu'il faut
pas qu'on des vents du changement mais
je crois qu'il faut et il faut intégrer
ça mais je dis ça je ne suis candidat à
rien je ne veux pas être donc je suis
désintéressé dans la vie politique je
suis mon mandat de sénateur et je suis
passionné par la commission de politique
étrangère
je peux vous dire que si on comprend pas
que nous devons changer nos attitudes on
vint vers des risques politiques
majeures très bien on a compris votre
message
merci une fois de plus jean pierre
raffarin d'avoir été avec nous en ce
mardi bonsoir à tout ça très vite
le